avec le vieillissement de la population
de plus en plus de gens ont besoin
d'être pour prendre soin de leurs pieds
c'est le cas de pierre est le gros
incapable de taille est elle-même ses
ongles d'orteil elle fait donc appel à
une employée d'une clinique près de chez
elle mais l'an dernier il la blesse en
lui retirant une partie de l'ongle du
gros orteil schaaf et progrès l'homme
n'avait pas les compétences pour faire
une telle intervention
poursuivi par l'ordre des podiatres il a
plaidé coupable à quatre chefs
d'infraction
ce cas illustre la confusion dans le
domaine des soins de pieds ou travail
des professionnels pédiatre et
infirmières et des non professionnels
qui ne sont pas régis par un ordre leur
formation qui se fait au privé n'est pas
encadré il ya eu à peu près mais non
professionnels qui sont peu qualifiés
pour faire ce qu'ils font et qui
malheureusement
près ce qui devrait pas traiter le
problème certains d'entre eux s'aventure
dans le champ médical pour faire passer
le message les ordres des podiatres des
infirmières et infirmières auxiliaires
viennent de publier des balises
l'objectif de ce sera par là dans une
perspective de protection du public
c'est que chacun agisse dans les limites
de ses connaissances et ses compétences
parmi les recommandations que les non
professionnels
aussi connu sous le nom de podologue
s'en tiennent à des soins comme la
taille des ongles la réduction des corps
et callosités l'application de crème
qu'il n'utilise plus d' instrument
tranchant et qu'il ne voit plus de
clients qui ont des problèmes de santé à
risque de complications comme le diabète
la principale association québécoise de
podologue aurait aimé être consultés
si ils veulent nous éliminer
mais c'est dommage pour le public parce
que le public est très contente d'avoir
des gens avec autant de facilité d'accès
un an après sa mésaventure l'ongle
d'orteils de pierrette legros n'est pas
complètement revenue à la normale avant
de faire donner des choix que j'ai fait
ici marie france bélanger radio canada
montréal